my name is Kendall Thomas I'm the Nash
professor of law and the director of the
Center for the Study of law and culture
the Center for the study of law and
culture at Columbia is a platform for
research and teaching and public events
that explore the interaction between law
and the arts anthropological and
sociological conceptions of culture and
more broadly the idea of culture as the
realm of our social life in which we
engage in the active work of making
things mean how does law in addition to
resolving disputes and structuring
social life operate as one of the
central sites for the production of
meaning for individuals and for groups
and the broader society